I know that you guys read some texts and
you probably know a lot about what I'm
going to talk about but I'm coming in
not from the academic point of view but
from a practitioner of the of the
religion and somebody who represents it
for a huge majority of it so let me
start my talk by saying that I didn't
realize I was such a good Christian
who's constantly in prayer it seems
that's what it means that it can explain
a little bit about the misunderstanding
between the Christian and there was some
way of seeing this karf the second thing
is I want you to imagine Cindy Crawford
ten years ago there beautiful you know
hair in a red dress short red dress on a
Jaguar and that's an ad to saw the car
with her long legs seductively leaning
now take her out and put me there as I
look right now
exactly
the whole point is that the difference
is that suddenly the sexuality issue
comes right at it how do you use women
women have been used to sell things
their sexuality has been put in the
public sphere to attract male gaze but
also the male financial pocket because
you know Cindy Crawford is not going to
marry you watching her on TV she's going
to get you to think if I get that car
hmm you know and actually it's true if
you get that car perhaps
so today in the faith and gender and the
headscarf issue sexuality is at the
center of the debate whether women are
subjugated for exposing it too much or
covering it up and of course I am the
cover-up part globalization and I'm sure
you've done this throughout the semester
is seen as a one-way invasion of Western
values across the world this is may not
be the place where this would be a
dominant point of view I the reason you
guys are here is that you believe that
there are different way validation can
be utilized to help the world but if you
come from my part of the world you see
it as McDonald in Mecca you see it as
somebody telling you how you should
behave how you should be and if you're
not then you are less than what your
potential is that the way you are is not
acceptable and that's something we don't
even tell kids we we prevent parents
from doing this to their children of
saying that the way you are is something
wrong and yet there's this whole
movement of doing that to a huge group
of people there's a problem with
globalization or the way people
understand it and through classes like
this one it's supposed to help leaders
emerging leaders like yourself change
the way that global globalization is
used but globalization also has a great
advantage especially when it comes to
gender is that it suddenly opened up a
lot of role models or different ideas of
what is to be a woman and people
suddenly have at their disposal
you know role models that they didn't
have before they can see Sandra O'Connor
as a judge well although she has stepped
down and I saw T Moyer Sotomayor is the
new ones Sotomayor or they can see you
know Oprah Winfrey or they can see
somebody else who has done something
great in their community that was
showcased so suddenly it opened up a lot
of great role models for many people
that didn't have them
but the problem is that the respect kind
of flowed one way we respected those
role models but the respect didn't flow
the other way around people didn't
respect our role models or the way that
we saw ourselves or the way that we
thought our duties were important our
priorities were important so the
headscarf is one of those global issue
that has you know risen out of those
kind of considerations is that just
because I wear a headscarf does that
mean I'm [ __ ] does that mean I am
somebody who's brainwashed because a lot
of people including Sarkozy that's what
it means if I wear a headscarf if I
choose to do something that the West
does not approve of then I am prevented
from going to school
I am prevented from applying for public
sector jobs which is where the majority
of women go to and this is in the cradle
of civilization this is in the cradle of
Liberty this is in France and that's
what makes it more problematic because
if it happens in France then it can
happen anywhere else in the world in the
free world so this is one part of my
talk about what does the headscarf mean
and this idea of globalization flowing
in both ways the other part of it is
that I'm here to represent a certain
point of view a particular point of view
that you may not agree with that might
contradict the way that you see the
world so for example my reference is the
Quran it's not somebody else it's not
what society as a whole thing's is great
it's what the Quran says and the reason
my reference is the Quran that I believe
it came from God that God is omniscient
that he knows everything that he created
a system it might it might look very
chaotic but male and female relationship
is just the same as the moon in the Sun
it is part of the natural order and
therefore when he tells us there are
certain things we should observe there's
a reason for it and if you go outside of
it there are huge consequences it
doesn't mean you're not going to go
outside of it it just means that beware
once you go out of that system
a lot of defects start to happen in in
the way that you're going to live your
life that everything is well planned so
I think that to a lot of people who rely
on human beings for their own decisions
this becomes problematic so I can't say
the Quran is my reference point but I
can say that the Constitution is so the
Constitution becomes my Quran in the US
it's okay to say that but if I say it's
the Quran only as a religious authority
then that somehow makes me backwards
makes me subjugate it to to a
hierarchical system that takes away my
rights and when it comes to male and
female relationship because this is what
gender is about it's about the other
male/female Islam has a very particular
point of view about why these two
genders or these two sexes were created
it is to preserve a family family is the
most important point in the religion is
not the male or the female so it's not
about losing rights and for a female or
gaining rights for a male it's about how
does the family stay intact how do you
actually protect the children so
physically women are weak we can say
there are some exceptions but most women
are weaker than men the way they were
built we have different physical things
that happen to us that don't happen to
men and we go through nine months of
pregnancy that actually pulls nutrients
out of our bodies it's a moment of
weakness for us and to pretend that this
does not exist that women are supposed
to function exactly the same as men and
or despite of that is a point that we
have a problem with in Islam so when a
woman is at her weakest which is when
she's pregnant or she has very young
children in Islam it's supposed to be
about the society and the men supporting
her so that she does not have to take on
more duties or work outside of the house
if she chooses to and the penalty is you
know part of it is that men
unfortunately get attracted to women
through their visual appearances and
wearing the scarf is part of actually
containing this it may not seem fair it
may not seem illogical but we think that
women should be treated outside of the
private sphere where she can be as
sexual as she wants to be in her family
versus outside where she needs to be
treated as to be tweaked in that area
and part of it is wearing the scarf
again as I said this is a very
particular point of view that you may
not agree with but part of the
globalization is that instead of saying
well this is the wrong point of view is
sort of saying well you know what if it
works for that culture and if this is
what they like then it's fine we're fine
with it versus if you do it then I'm
going to take rights of Education what
so health care right to work away from
you because you chose that and this is
what is actually happening right now and
there are two things about the job that
is very problematic is that most people
confuse what her job is
so they think niqab which is covering
the face is her job know hey job is
exactly what I'm wearing something that
is covering the hair loosely or the hair
can show a little bit it doesn't have to
show whatever but this is what her job
is
the club is covering the face niqab is
not in Islam it's a cultural thing but a
significant minority in Saudi Arabia
where I come from Egypt Pakistan
actually where then they choose to wear
it my problem with that is if they say
that Islam tells us to do that because
Islam doesn't and a lot of them don't
even understand their own religion
unfortunately but so their understanding
of it as being mandatory is problematic
for me because it is explicitly not
mandatory in Islam the other part is
that
as much as personally I dislike it I
don't want somebody to tell me whether I
can cover or not cover my face I don't
want somebody to tell me whether I can
wear you know a Halloween costume or not
or a Halloween costume
you know so I understand the security
issue that France might have but I think
that it is not really a security issue
that they were talking about it was
really a very it's a form of
discrimination against Muslims they
don't want to see Frances identity
changing and wearing the scarf wearing
the niqab is kind of like a symbol of
France changing and that is very
uncomfortable Europe is going to go
through a very uncomfortable time in the
next 50 years as more immigrants
practice their own religion or way of
life or look different because it's a
question of identity how do you
negotiate what does it mean to be French
if half the people who are French no
longer look French who might have
another passport another language
another religion so this these are all
difficult questions right now France is
dealing with it by saying we're just
going to pretend everything is hidden
and it won't work for long yeah so again
we go back to the high job and as I said
the particular point of view is that
you're not supposed to send sexual
messages to the wrong party you're not
so it's supposed to be something that is
very private between you and your
husband this is why it is allowed when
you're getting engaged and when you're
when you're married and within your
family to look as beautiful as you want
to be Eve you know that red dress you
may not look like Cindy Crawford but you
can wear it whereas outside of the the
family then no your is not about a
sexual rule that you play it is about a
human role that you play and that does
not need the short red dress what has
happened is that people take Saudi
Arabia as the example for the job issue
where it is mandatory not that you wear
the hijab only if you're Saudi but that
you were a black eye by have you seen
those and so this is kind of like a
traditional thing that we do and people
take that to mean Islam it's quite
traditional and
uh you know it is only particularly to
Saudi Arabia Saudi Arabia is only 1 out
of 100 countries that have huge Muslim
numbers in it people don't look at the
others to say the same thing now I'm
actually one of those people who like
that ayah because I was telling dr. wolf
earlier on if you have to run out of the
house in five minutes wearing your
sweatpants it's so easy to just like
buzzing that I buy it looks really
gorgeous and go to a meeting nobody
knows what you're wearing it so for me
as a mother it has saved me numerous
times and but again I think it's a
cultural thing where we actually like it
my issue is that whether you have a
choice of wearing it or not and I'm one
of those people who believes that you
should have a choice Kuwait is a great
example of a country that is very close
to us that actually does this you can
wear that I buy if you want to you can
wear the hijab which is like this or you
can not wear it it's up to you it's up
to what you decide with your family or
with your own tribe or whatever it is
because it does a designee sometimes
certain status what you want to be and
one of the the cutest stories that I've
ever had is that in Kuwait
I approached somebody and I spoke Arabic
to them because I needed information I
was lost and the person who was wearing
the full abaya with the black hijab
looked exactly like me doesn't speak in
Arabic she was from Pakistan she spoke
English and Urdu and but she has decided
to actually wear that this way although
she's living in Kuwait so I like that I
like this idea of having the choice to
choose how you want to do it and that's
where globalization comes in as people
get access to different role models then
stop start to rebel against having one
way of dictating what you need to look
like and actually start choosing it so
hopefully globalization will help us in
that so as I said this is supposed to be
more of a conversation I presented my
point of view and you guys have your own
readings and you can actually ask
questions if you would like if you don't
that's fine too